we must restore the peace so that we can
do this hard work together I want to
know what George's girlfriend Courtney
said about George he was all about love
and all about peace he did not receive
that love and that peace from our
officers on the night of May 25th but we
can still honor him by practicing those
values during a time of great strife
that is the task ahead of us and at this
time when one crisis is sandwiched
against another this could be the marker
this could be a point in time when
several years from now we can look back
to know that we rose to right the wrongs
of the past not just with words but with
action we will be working with community
we need to be working with community to
sort through those set of action steps
time when we were picked up the rubble a
time where we picked up the rubble the
glass and found peace in our hearts not
an ignorant piece but an awakened one
where we can truly make change possible
and so in the coming days we will have
an all-out effort to restore peace and
security in our city I've authorized a
unified command structure that allows
our chief arredondo to utilize resources
personnel from other jurisdictions we've
requested assistance from the state and
we are thankful to the governor for the
support as well as from the State Patrol
this work is about protecting community
this work is about protecting
infrastructure needed to get through
this pandemic together our communities
need these assets especially during a
pandemic our communities need grocery
stores for food many banks for cash we
need pharmacies for needed medication
let's hold these communities dear by
doing right by them and by safeguarding
them and these community assets that we
know they need especially during a
pandemic we need to offer radical love
and compassion that we all have in us I
believe in this city and I know that you
do too
next I would like to invite off council
vice president Andrea Jenkins who has
been a tremendous leader amazing grace
how sweet is the sign that has like me I
grew up in the religious family
religious home I grew up in the church
with Reverend Jeremiah Wright and he
talked about these and justices every
Sunday I want to offer some amazing
grace - Bridgette Floyd to fill a nice
Floyd - Tara Floyd
Rodney Floyd to the entire Floyd family
my deepest condolences and sympathies
are with you in this in this traumatic
tragic moment of grief I also stand here
to grieve with my community today with
all the black
people all throughout this country all
throughout America and right here in
Minneapolis we feel as if there was a
need on all of our collective necks a
need that says black life does not
matter to the institutions that dictate
what happens in this culture and society
I am a part of this system to help to
take that knee off of our necks
that is the work that I will be doing as
we stand here grieving yet another loss
of black life a senseless tragic loss of
black life I I really don't have many
words but I know that something's got to
change and so I am asking my colleagues
the mayor and anyone else who is
concerned about the state of affairs in
our community to declare a state of
emergency declaring racism as a public
health issue until we name this virus
this disease that has infected America
for the past 400 years we will never
ever resolve this issue to those who say
bringing up racism is racist in and of
itself I say to you if you don't call
cancer what it is you can never cure
that disease and so in an effort to try
and cure this disease I am stating
exactly what everyone else has witnessed
in that is racism today is a sad day for
Minneapolis it's a sad day for America
it's a sad day for the world I want to
remind all of the people that are in the
streets protesting you have every
absolute right to be angry to be upset
to be mad to express your anger however
you have no right to perpetrate violence
and harm on the very communities that
you say that you are standing up for we
need peace and calm in our streets and I
am begging you for that we will be
working with black community leaders to
develop and create a healing space at
the site of the third Precinct so that
people can grieve express their concerns
their anger
in a safe and humane way this is a
tragic moment like mere fry I love the
city of Minneapolis I have spent the
last 41 years as a resident of the city
and this is my home and we cannot allow
outsiders or our own minion Politan
residents to destroy our city so we want
to work together to ensure that people
have their voices heard in a safe and in
a safe manner and that's my commitment
in the words of Leroy a Williams who was
a first-hand I witness to mr. George
Floyd's terrible demise we got to make a
change bro thank you
Thank You mayor Frey Thank You council
vice president Jenkins I want to first
by saying that I'm absolutely sorry for
the pain the devastation and the trauma
that mr. Floyd's death has left on his
family his loved one our community here
in Minneapolis and certainly across the
country in the world and I know that our
community is in trauma and that they are
trying to find ways to heal from the
very beginning I wanted to make sure and
ensure and we will continue to do that
that those who are wanting to express
their First Amendment rights and go
through this healing process that they
will absolutely have that from me and
that is a guarantee as your chief but
that being said even prior to mr.
Floyd's death we have had a community
that has been in trauma for quite some
time and what I cannot allow is chief is
for others to compound that trauma and
so if individuals as occurred last night
are committing behavior and acts which
are criminal which are looting our
businesses as consul ice president
Jenkins had mentioned are so vital to
the health and vitality of our community
if their looting those stores if they're
robbing people of essential needs and
services for themselves their families
and certainly in this pandemic their
loved ones if they are setting buildings
and structures on fire which are harming
the safety of our elderly and our youth
I cannot allow that as chief and so I
know that there is currently a deficit
of hope in our city and as I wear this
uniform before you I know that this
department has contributed to that
deficit of Hope but I will not allow to
continue to increase that deficit by
reach Ramat izing those folks in our
community so I am committed to making
sure that we restore peace and security
in our community
as Mira Frye said we are going to have a
unified command system we are going to
have resources to to make sure again
that all parts of our city from the
Philips neighborhood to North
Minneapolis to downtown that all of our
sections of our city have that we want
to continue to make sure that community
can come and gather in spaces to again
to heal to to grieve in honor certainly
of mr. Floyd but I cannot allow criminal
acts to occur and threaten the safety
and and also again compound the trauma
that already exists I have been in
constant communication with community
leaders members from our faith community
community healers and as both mayor Frey
and council vice president Jenkins had
mentioned they want to make sure that we
have that space in a safe space for
those folks to do that and so we will
continue to do that but again I also
again want to just acknowledge my
condolences to mr. Floyd his family and
friends thank you
what we experienced which was a
different dynamic shift from the first
evening of the demonstrations were there
was a different tenor last night there
was a different group of individuals and
I want to preface this the vast majority
of people that have come together have
been doing so peacefully but there was a
core group of people that had really
been focused on causing some destruction
certainly we saw that with some of the
looting and and setting fires we were
certainly prepared in terms of that
immediate area to provide for the safety
but if any of you followed of course the
events last night the crowds got larger
and they became more mobile and and so
it you know our number one priority is
the preservation of life and so we
wanted to make sure that we were looking
at that from those who are gathering
peacefully in the area who were also
being threatened and risked our
neighboring residents and also those
businesses and so there was a shift that
certainly occurred last night
we continue to follow that information
that Intel
I'm keeping the mayor briefed on that as
we speak I I will just say that it was
clear to me and also hearing from our
local community leaders that many of the
people that were involved in the
criminal conduct last night were not
known many ippolit ins to them and so so
yes there were certainly people who were
involved in the activities last night
that were certainly not recognized as
being here from the city so we did have
some reports of injuries to some of our
police officers I'm happy to report that
no significant injuries there were some
community members who were out there
demonstrating who also suffered some
minor injuries and again fortunately no
significant injuries that I am aware of
mayor Frye in terms of a National Guard
request mayor Frye is the only person
that can make that formal declaration
and as he mentioned he has had
conversations with governor waltz well
one of the things that I'm very proud of
also being a born and raised here in the
city over the course of the last several
days I've been talking to many of the
friends family in our broader community
who have said they want to make sure
that even though we're experiencing
trauma and pain and grief in our city
they don't want to exacerbate that so
they're going to be out there you're
going to start seeing more of our again
community healers faith leaders our
elders and even our youth and so I think
you'll see a shift in that today so I'm
I'm always hopeful because it's the same
community that has supported me
throughout my my career
yes I have made that phone call to the
governor and has been requested the
governor and the state have been have
been very helpful but I would further
direct that that I believe will they'll
be in contact shortly I have not as of
this point this morning these businesses
are staples in the community
many of them are long-standing
institutions but more importantly in the
time of a pandemic they're essential for
community needs ranging from food to
financial services these are pieces of
our community that we're going to need
over the coming weeks and months when
you have one crisis that is sandwiched
on top of another it's all the more
important that we're able to yes keep
community safe and also keep these very
critical pieces safe and I've spoken
with the chief and that that is most
certainly part of the plan as we move
towards tonight in the coming days
I've heard the the same thing I do know
that at the time the incident occurred
there was a lot of information that was
that was developing and changing and so
I have heard that and it is never
certainly my intention to to put out
information that would cause some of the
the pain that others have felt and or
even doubt some of the the information
that was coming out and I'm committed
that as we move forward that we will do
better to make sure that we're getting
as much factual information out is a
timely manner as we can unfortunately I
don't have all the details to that but I
get back we've got two priorities the
first party always is going to be the
preservation of life at some point in
time during the evening the the events
really sort of migrated away from the
precinct and also it came down to a
matter of resources I tell you that when
you have fires that take place
chief Friedel now certainly let him
speak but we cannot allow and he
certainly won't allow his men and women
to go in there and take care of those
fires if they're not protected and so
that also shifted resources and we you
know we certainly are never expecting
these types of gatherings to involve
arson but once that dynamic shifted it
required other resources policing
resources to assist the chief and it's
very difficult for me again I'm born and
raised here in Minneapolis and a central
neighborhood kid this is it's very
difficult and I have an obligation to
our 400,000 plus residents visitors and
workers to provide that sense of trust
and safety and so it is very difficult
but I but I'm hopeful and I'm optimistic
because again the vast majority of our
Minneapolis community was not
participating in the criminal conduct
that occurred last night and and and so
they have also continued to be in
communication with myself
obviously mayor fryin council vice
president Jenkins that they are really
going to you're going to see more of a
footprint from our community out there
in support of the piece that we all want
we are gonna be conducting some
strategizing sessions over the coming
days obviously one of the the
difficulties we have is facing a 165 to
200 million dollar revenue shortfall and
then expenses that are resourced towards
kovat 19 the monies that we have
available are presently somewhat limited
but this sort of calls the the question
of how much we do need assistance from
the federal and state government now we
needed it before this killing took place
it's all the more essential after thank
you
I just got some some information this
morning after we sort of sort of Wong
down little bit early this morning I
think we had 16 structure fires last
night we probably had a few additional
runs related to fire but not necessarily
structures and involved no you know 14
we had no injuries of firefighters and I
had no reported injuries to any
civilians ya know in in in what will
happen is when we we establish unified
command structure unified command
structure is just bringing when we start
bringing additional resources to assist
us whether it be fire please whoever
when you bring additional resources we
unify a command structure in other words
there's representation from all of those
resources that come in there is somebody
from that resource who is part of that
command team that makes us that helps us
be able to develop a much more effective
plan to address issues we're facing and
so in its way that they've become you
know intimately involved with
establishing a plan to move forward